on dit néanmoins qu'à plus de médecins
en allemagne qu'en france 4 3 pour mille
en allemagne 3 4 pour mille ans en
france
cela n'a pas joué pour vous c'est
vraiment une preuve un problème de de
bureaucratie qui serait plus importante
en france qu'en allemagne
je pense que c'est un équipage crédit à
la bureaucratie parce que l'allemagne
est capable d'être très bureaucratique
elle aussi quand elle le veut mais le
fait que les décisions aient pu être
prise au plus près du terrain
c'est le comme je le disais tout à
l'heure les agences locales de santé
publique elle son niveau infra
régionales elle coordonne les les
interventions hospitalière en k2 en cas
de pandémie a au niveau de plusieurs
villes à l'intérieur d'un lente donc ça
ça a été extrêmement important et ce qui
fait qu'il ya on a on appuie t de perdre
tant on a perdu en france avec des
allers-retours permanents entre entre
paris entre paris et les régions
ça c'est à mon avis la différence
fondamentale
le différentiel du nombre de médecins ne
me semble pas avoir un obstacle absolu
du côté français en revanche la halle à
l'immixtion permanente du pouvoir
central dans le poindre processus vous
donner un autre exemple qui n'est pas
liée là directement la médecine mais qui
est liée à l'état de confinement là au
niveau fédéral on a fixé un état minimal
du confinement
c'est c'est ce seul confinement que
l'allemagne a mis en place depuis depuis
le 15 mars à peu près en certains länder
ont comme la bavière ont décidé d'avoir
un confinement plus plus fort mais on
les a laissés faire c'était de leur
responsabilité et est ce qui a permis
d'avoir un confinement différencier
correspondant à l'état de gravité de la
pandémie selon l'heure
oui
[Musique]